behind the decades of exploration of
outer space with its infinite horizons
and limited access and the fiery risk of
writing to roman candles to get there
are women who broke into a long-standing
all-male culture and blazed a trail for
others to follow in their footsteps
with so many popular narratives
revealing the achievements of space
heroines it's hard to imagine that there
was a time when the cosmos was
off-limits to women the first artificial
Earth satellite will today successfully
launch in the USSR when the Soviets
launched Sputnik in 1957 America also
entered this space age Moscow newspapers
were birth Roger I had blasted a
man-made moon into outer space Sputnik
was a dramatic wake-up call that
threatened America's presumed
technological supremacy
President Dwight Eisenhower replaced
NACA the National Advisory Committee for
Aeronautics with NASA the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration and
authorized a program to put a human in
space
the race was on
we have one of the most challenging
assignments that has ever been given to
modern man I've first became aware of
the space program when I was in graduate
school everyone was very excited about
it this was all being done for the first
time so it was her trying to figure out
how to do the nation's mercury
astronauts I got on this project because
it'd probably be the nearest to heaven
I'd ever get and I wanted to make the
most of it I would give my left arm to
be the first man in space all the guys
are very smart good education is test
pilot schools young good-looking and
they knew it and they were what you
would imagine astronauts would be like
they're Soviets beat the US again in
1961 sending a cosmonaut around the
earth one extraordinary revolutionary
time the pressure was on to get an
American into space behind the scenes
NACA had been employing women to crunch
numbers since the 1930s later this
included recruiting african-american
women with college degrees to work in
segregated pools as human computers no
longer varied in history their stories
told in the best-selling book and hip
film hidden figures the mathematicians
of the Mercury program are the ones who
finally helped put the first Americans
in space what a fool miles per hour of
46 point 56 the calculations of
Katherine Johnson who worked at NASA for
33 years would go on to help land the
first humans on the moon in 1969 and win
the space race for the United States but
breaking into the astronaut corps for
women was impossible
you think it can compete with many I'm
not competing with the man at all I
think that both men and women will be
flying in space
Jerry Cobb and a group of aspiring
female astronauts were invited to go
through the same exams as the mercury
men despite the fact that the women
passed the test with flying colors
the program was abruptly canceled at
that time a cream in our country was it
their jobs women could do in jobs they
shouldn't do and they could fly
airplanes as good as men and they wanted
to be in space too they didn't want to
go instead of the men they just wanted
to go also but they never were approved
for flight
meanwhile the Soviets beat the us again
when valentina Tereshkova became the
first female to fly in space
finally the 1972 Equal Employment
Opportunity Act opened the doors for
women in workplaces across the country
that was a turning point if you were
qualified and if the job did not require
a man then women should be considered
and there was no reason that we could
say the job of being an astronaut
required that you be a man and that's 35
new astronauts so we ended up selecting
six women for that first class they were
smart and they all had it then you got
the impression from talking to them that
if they wanted to do something they
would get it done this group of
astronauts included Sally Ride the first
American woman in space Katherine
Sullivan the first American woman to
spacewalk and Anna Fisher the first
mother to fly in space it was their
tremendous competence that paved the way
for more first women including Eileen
Collins NASA's first female pilot and
Commander mae Jemison the first
african-american woman to fly
ellen ochoa the first latina kalpana
chawla the first woman of indian origin
Kate Rubin's the first person to
sequence DNA in orbit and Peggy Whitson
who in 2017 set the record for the most
cumulative time in space by any u.s.
astronaut if you yourself is a role
model of any kind for young women it's
not something I think about a lot but I
know that the first female astronaut
selected were definitely an inspiration
to me and so I maybe I will be a role
model
I think the role model issue is one that
makes us all kind of think about things
that did not set out to be a role model
I set out to do a job and try to be good
at it women can do whatever they set
their minds to do I think the lesson
we've learned is that if they want to do
it they should be given the opportunity
it is a tribute to these Trailblazers
that it now seems positively antiquated
to think there was a time that women
were not allowed in I was very honored
that the NASA chose me to be the first
woman it's time that that people realize
that women in this country can do any
job that they want to do
if history has taught us anything and as
first females well know every small step
by one is a giant advance for us all
you